Which x values ​​make the ordered pair
x seventh minus 7 decision of
the following inequality?
Inequality is 2x minus 7e
less than 25.
And we have several options, as I recommend you
pause the video and see if you can find it
alone.
Okay, now let's solve it together.
We are given the condition that y should be equal to
minus 7.
And if we mean that condition, we can substitute
this y with a minus 7.
So we can write inequality as 2x minus 7
by minus 7 because we limit y to be
minus 7, is less than 25.
And this will be 2x minus 49
or 2x plus 49 is less than 25.
Now if I want to isolate only x on one side,
what we see in these inequalities here above,
we can get 49 on both sides.
So we get 49 on both sides and we get
2x is less than, let's see, 49 minus 25
will be plus 24, so it will be
minus 24.
Now, to isolate x, we just have to divide both sides into 2
and we will not change inequality because
multiply or divide by a positive value.
Plus 2.
This will be x is less than minus 12.
And luckily, this is one of the answers listed.
Therefore, while, if y is equal to minus 7,
while x is less than minus 12, will
we are grateful for this inequality.
Let's solve one more of these tasks.
Like this one is a little bit more apparent.
So what values ​​do the ordered couple do,
in the last task we had a condition for y,
and we found the x values
will satisfy this inequality.
Now we have the opposite case.
We have a x condition and say,
what values ​​of y will make the ordered pair true.
Or they will make a decision.
Which values ​​for y will make the ordered 5-digit pair y
a solution to the inequality presented by
the graph below?
This is not given us algebraically, it is given to us
visually.
To be a solution, that means we have to be
in this blue area.
So, this pair, minus 5
comma 6.
It will be a solution to the inequality that is depicted.
Something that sits right on the right,
it will not be a solution because you pay attention to the rights, as you see
this lower boundary line is interrupted.
If it was dense, then all rights would be
solution.
But since it is interrupted, things from the rights
are not solutions.
Only the things that are above the rights will be
solutions.
So let's see what we want to find.
It is said, the condition is x to be
equal to 5.
So, x equal to 5 is everything,
to see if I can draw it.
x equal to 5 is all on
this is where I am.
Now, assuming x is equal to 5,
we will be somewhere on this right,
how should we restrict y to make sure,
that we will be in the decision zone?
Well, we have to limit ourselves so,
that we are above the rights to
x equal to 5, just to clarify.
We must be above,
the possible points will be those,
once again, we limit x equal to 5,
possible points are those,
which I stain with purple.
And in fact, I can go on if I want to.
y must be greater than,
it can not be greater than or equal to 7,
it should be greater than 7.
If it was greater than or equal to 7,
we would include the point of rights,
but I have already explained about this interrupted right,
so we do not want to include the rights points.
We want to include the points over the rights.
Therefore, y will be greater than 7,
which is the answer there.
If x is equal to 5 while y is
greater than 7 we will be
in the multitude of decisions.